Tonight, House Speaker Kevin
McCarthy telling reporters
he is okay
with embattled Republican George Santos
attending classified briefings.
The full House is set to be brie
on China tomorrow morning.
And this comes with Santos
defending himself against attack
Former Senator Mitt Romney,
who told him that
he didn't belong in Congress.
In this tense exchange
just before
last night's state of the Union
it's not the first time in histo
that I've been told to shut up
and go to the back of the room,
especially by people
who come from a privileged backg
And it's not going to be the las
And I'm never going to shut up
and go to the back of the room.
And I think it's reprehensible
that the senator would say
such a thing to me in the demean
He said it wasn't very Mormon of
That's what I can tell you.
Thinking
about privilege
while Santos facing
growing calls to resign
not because of privilege,
but because of his many lies
with one of his fellow Republica
calling him a, quote, sociopath
even the end is OUTFRONT
New York three Santos raising
the spate of lies
from freshman
Congressman Jorge
Santos have done more than anger
His constituents.
It's also raising
serious questions about why Sant
constantly lies
when we're talking
about pathological lying.
We have a clear cut
example in the headlines every d
Christian Hart is a psychologist
who directs the Human
Deception Laboratory
at Texas Woman's University.
What is a pathological liar?
Someone who has a maladaptive
pattern of lying.
The person tends to lie excessiv
so they're prolifically lying.
Telling the lies typically cause
a lot of problems in their life.
Problems with relationships, pro
in the workplace,
sometimes legal problems
among Santos lies that have been
in the months
following his election include.
I actually went to school on
on a volleyball scholarship.
My mom was a nine 11 survivor
I'm a Latino Jew.
My grandparents survived the Hol
Also founded my own
nonprofit organization.
While it's still unclear
what is motivating Santos's lies
Psychologists like Hart
say there's always a reason
people don't lie at random.
They believe there won't be
repercussions for their lying.
And then also they can somehow
morally justify their lying
or prove to themselves
that they're still an okay perso
I've lived an honest life.
I've never been
accused should of anything bad d
Without meeting Santos,
he can't diagnose him
but says his pervasive line
does say something about him.
When we see
people telling egregious lies li
and there appears to be
a lifelong pattern associated wi
I would say certainly he's
he seems to be the type of perso
who's engaging in pathological l
There was this moment
at the State of the Union addres
where Senator Romney approached
and he didn't seem apologetic at
We see this pattern a lot.
And people
with psychopathic tendencies
or people
with antisocial personality diso
And in those cases,
what we find is that
those people are extremely comfo
manipulating and using
and exploiting people.
And they do
so with very little guilt or sha
and tend not to have remorse.
And heart says that for
those that are pathological liar
it's not so easy to detect.
They seemed to be making
a completely truthful
and compelling case.
It's only when we look
for the evidence that we see
that that was a lie.
And need tonight.
Erin, our colleague Kit
Maher has learned
Democratic Congressman
Robert Garcia of California, he'
introducing a resolution
to expel Congressman Santos tomo
Now, this is significant
because this marks
the first official expulsion
resolution that has been introdu
against the Long Island Republic
But don't expect this to go far.
That resolution
not anticipated
to be brought up for a floor
vote in the Republican led House
and will instead
be referred to the Ethics Commit
All right, Erin,
thank you very much for your rep
And now let's
bring in Republican Congressman
Anthony Esposito of New York,
who is the first House
Republican to call on Santos
to step down.
And Congressman,
I really appreciate your time.
So the House speaker, Kevin
McCarthy, tells CNN tonight
he's okay
with Santos attending tomorrow's
briefing on China.
It's a classified briefing
Do you agree with that?
Well, I definitely do have some
I think the fact that Jorge Sant
we didn't feel was
should have the ability
to serve on committees.
I don't think that he should be
on serving,
you know,
or hearing any briefings either.
You know, I've
told my staff that
any letters that are being sent
you know, group letters about
certain policies,
if Jorge Santos, his name on it,
I don't want to be involved.
I'd rather send one on my own.
You know, he's taken this instit
and really made it a laughingsto
I mean, people from throughout
this country are now focused.
And Jorge Santos
has become somewhat of a househo
And it's not for anything good.
I mean, when you are
constantly on Saturday
Night Live
and the nightly shows being mock
because you literally lied your
to the halls
of the United States Congress.
You know, I agree with my collea
from New York and Long Island,
and I agree with what
Senator Romney said last night.
There was just no reason
for Santos to even be there
and definitely not sitting on th
because he knew
that he was going
to catch the eyes of cameras
and journalists.
And that's exactly what he wants
and that's exactly what he likes
It was clear he wanted that.
Now, the House speaker, Kevin Mc
of course, has refused
to join you, Congressman,
in calling on Santos to resign.
His most recent quote,
is, if ethics finds something,
we'll take action.
And he's referring to the Ethics
Committee. I'm sure. I'm sure.
Broadly speaking,
he understands where we are
ethically on this issue.
He's talking with the committee
Is that enough, in your view?
Listen, I
think that the speaker has taken
this role as our leader,
and he is looking at as at this
from a broad view.
And I think that he's making
the best decisions for
for all of us and for this insti
And I know that we've had conver
many of the New York delegation
that have called for his resigna
We've had conversations
with all the leadership.
They've been super open and supp
They understand that
where we're coming from.
And I believe that, you know,
Speaker McCarthy has the best in
of all of us at hand.
And I know that when ethics revi
I think we're all pretty clear
where that's going to end up. Ri
And I think it's important to em
you all are from where he's from
This is in New York
and speaking from
you know,
this isn't someone coming from f
last night.
I know it was your first State
of the Union address
as a member of Congress,
but it was unlike any
that we've ever seen
or certainly
that you would have seen as a vi
But you were in the room.
Some of your fellow Republicans
heckled President Biden.
Here's just one example.
Fentanyl is killing more
than 70,000 Americans a year.
You got it.
The Wall Street Journal
Now, of course,
Congressman, that wasn't
that wasn't
the majority of your of your par
And the president made that clea
But but there were plenty of the
And it was it was constant.
It was heckling.
Do you think it was appropriate?
I think people are frustrated.
You know,
some of the things
that the president said
although I think he meant well
and he did explain and try to pu
a bipartisan future for for all
and for America.
I think there were certain issue
that he focused on that
perhaps he wasn't lying,
but he definitely wasn't
giving the whole truth.
And, you know,
I don't want to speak for
any of my colleagues
but I know that there was
some frustration there,
many, many issues that I guess
they've been dealing with for lo
than I've been in Congress.
And it seemed that the president
didn't really want to focus on
the specific truths.
And like I said,
I think there was some frustrati
that probably got the best
of some people.
Congressman, thank you very much
I appreciate your time tonight.